were you ever reckless reckless
where it's like where it's like you got
a big speech the next morning yeah i
gotta act and you get just shit-faced
until two in the morning um i i'm gonna
say no
never [ __ ] liar i don't know how
people do it i can't do it i'm too
stressed you know what i know it gets me
hung over now
i just found out easter sugar
i had so much candy i woke up the next
day with a [ __ ] hangover the raven
the raven crazy ass scotsman who fights
and drinks like a [ __ ]
crazy man and and i had some too much
candy
at easter and i had a hangover the next
day
it's never again never again never again
have you ever like one time i got high
actually i got high once filming years
ago because i had very few lines that
day so i kind of smoked a little joint
washed
not a good idea i was so paranoid
why am i not doing it right am i am i
off am i off what's the matter
my your energy is kind of low you hit me
yeah i was paranoid it's horrible have
you done it too i've done that i still
watched it i did it doing macbeth when i
first started on on stage
i was [ __ ] the worst experience how
do you get stoned before oh listen
there's a snowy behind him
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast we we've been
rehearsing rehearsing rehearsing and you
know it was the first week we got the
first week under our belt
the six theater i think it was in
glasgow or
whatever the [ __ ] in glasgow
so we're the weekend and my friend shows
up in my apartment and he says oh i just
get this amazing weed it's called skunk
and i thought oh you know i'll try
something this is a long time ago kids
i said i'll try something up it's twelve
o'clock by seven o'clock cutting up i'll
be fine
no
i smoked some of that one o'clock i'm
still at my mind two o'clock three
o'clock four o'clock now you're getting
caught you're getting paid now i'm
breaking out even more because it's
getting closer to the curtain and i'm
just freaked out my mind
and um
then all of a sudden i'm on the stage
macbeth the dude
shakespeare's flying and you're still
high i'm high in my [ __ ] mind i
couldn't i can't i want to where am i
and then macbeth turns to me
who who wait is that the door or some
[ __ ] who are you playing i was playing
seton mentee
i played like four different colors oh
god oh lord yeah try that one so i'm
playing all these mad crazy characters
and then he says who's who knocketh on
the door which is not shaped
and that's not i don't know what it was
i i i she says to me who's knocking the
door nicely there's a couple of guys at
the door
which is definitely not shakespeare
and shakespeare shakespeare fans sit in
the audience and they turn the pages you
see him with the books and look i can
hear that that's not what he said i said
it's called guys at the door anyway
boring story but that's why you
shouldn't smoke marijuana kids did uh
robert carlisle who got you into acting
uh into
stage and stuff did he did he call you
out after do you say were you are you
high did he say anything to you didn't
you get any left probably do you have
any on you
yeah